はい それではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは不満ということで
満たされないのはなぜでしょうか？というひとつ
仏教のテーマになります
で まあ満たされないと言ったっても
大体はこのよくテレビで見たことで
日本の社会でアンケートなんかを取ると
今の人生に満足している人々は過半数になります
日本では世界の人間は大体文句ばかり言って生きているが
日本は日常生活において不満を感じることはなく
落ち着いているのですと
今日のお話はピント外れになるかもしれませんね
ですから 日本ではあまり不満を感じたということはないと思う
アンケートの結果ですからね
そういうことで まあ皆様にあまり関係ない話ですでも聞いてもらわないと困りますけどね
まあよく見ると もう自分が満足しているか
満足していないかとかね
まあ日本では考えたことがないでしょう
あんまり何一つも真剣に考えている人に会ったことがないんです
もしかするとその機能は遺伝的にすぎてないか
自分で 機能しないようにしているかどうかは
とにかくもう全部はっきりと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
ABC という順番だよとちゃんとラベルがあって
いくと ABC 順番 ああ
そうですか じゃあ CAB にするぞということになるんで
とにかく考える能力は必要なんです
なかなか物事を考えないんですから
問題がありますけどね
満足です はい 満足ですっていうだけで答え終わっちゃいます
休みなく暇がなく 夜遅くまで頑張らないと生きていられないということは
まあ幸福として見るべきか
不幸として見るべきかという疑問になるんです
これも日本の社会現象で
あの十分あの 頑張らないとね
朝から晩まで生きていられないんですね
まあとにかく忙しい ですから
ものすごい忙しいんだから
あんた満足ですか？とか
そんなこと聞いたって考えたこともないんです
で もうだからまあもう一応はいというところにもう丸入れて終わっちゃうんです
自分でもわからないんですよ
外国に行くときは 宗教はなんですか？と言えば
もうなんとか書くでしょうね
まさかなんで宗教だから宗教聞くでしょ
外国の場合は宗教というなんでマスサージュ学校の買い物することとか書かないんですかね
それ誰かに聞くんです
宗教なんでしょうかね
アグネスサンクやキリスト教やいろいろ
そうじゃあいいです なので
まあ結局はそういうことについて考えることはないし
暇がないということなんです
余計なことを考えず済みますから
忙しいのは一概に悪くないかもしれません
この忙しいっていうのは
そんな悪いことでもないんですよ
なぜかというと このまあ
いらんことを考えなくて済みますしね
いらんことを考えちゃうと
もうかなり混乱してね
世の中でトラブルが来るんですよ
少々人間に暇があると
もうとんでもないことを考えたりするんですね
妄想したりするんですね
それで人を殺したり いろんなことをやったりする
ですから 日本の社会では
まあそんな考える暇がないんです
犯罪を起こしたりとか
なんとかなんだかとかね
そういう余裕がないんだから
忙しいんですからね  それで平和な社会にはなってるんですね
だからまあ それ結果論で見れば
まあ決して悪いことじゃないと思いますよ
...殺し合いやって生きてるよりは
平和で生きている方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
そういうわけで この日本の社会ではね
みんなすごく忙しいということは一概に悪いことやとかね
それが不幸やとかは決して言えません
まあ結果的に見ると 忙しいことによって
みんな自分のことで忙しくて他人に迷惑をかける暇もないんだから
それで落ち着いているんですね
ですから 犯罪起こせなくなってるんですね
それは社会的に見ると悪いことじゃないんです
その犯罪を起こす機会っていうのは出てこないんですね
チャンスが忙しいんだから
だって世の中で人類みんなもう何の犯罪もしない
すごい心優しい人間にさせるということは無理でしょうに
人間にそんなあれこれと言っても
全然もう 悪いことをやめてくれませんし
良いことは言っても言ってもやらないしね
だから人間というのは
そんな説教したっても
どうどうと語っても変わるもんじゃないんですよ
だからといって放っておくと何するかわからない
ですから まあイスラム教だったら厳しい法律で国民をね
厳しく抑えているし ちょっとだけでも何かしたら
まあもう手を切ったり首を切ったりしてね
もうその場で撃って殺したりとかね
まあするんだから それは怖くて
まあ一応犯罪しないことになるでしょうと思いますし
日本ではそういうふうに法律的にいじめられてるわけでも何でもないし
自由でしょうし 楽しく気楽に生きていられるでしょうし
だからといって暴走しないで
みんな落ち着いているということは
朝から晩まで忙しいんだからなんですね
ですから この忙しいという現象は
まあによって結構守られているということは理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
それから満足しているというタイトルで
みんなこれ以上はどうにもならないと諦めていると思います
従って満足していると言わざるを得ないのです
でまあ 朝から晩まで頑張っているでしょうに
これ以上頑張りなさいと言ったって
もう時間ないんです だからどなたでもギリギリのところで
もう寝る暇もできるだけ切ってますね
寝る暇もできるだけ減らして減らして頑張ってるんですよ
これ以上頑張りなさいと言っちゃうと話にならないでしょ
ですから 一人一人を知ってますよ
自分が もう自分の能力と時間のもうギリギリでやっている
そう そうなってくると
あれ欲しい これ欲しいとかね
こうなりたい ああなりたいという
まあ将来的な欲望 希望っていうのはもう頭にないんですよ
だから今の生き方でもう結構
もうこりごり もう期待するものは何もない
という状況になって 満足しているということをしか言う言葉がないんですね
これで結構や まあ時々
まあ子育てに疲れている若おかお母さん
お母さんたちはね 一人の子供しかいないんだけど
もう一人とか もう十分や
もうこれではと という場合は
その一人の子供の面倒を見ることに
もう精一杯力全部なくなって
もう考えるだけでももう怪我出すんですよ
もう一人産むのかとかね
だからその一人と 例に出した人にとっては
もう自分がもうギリギリ精一杯頑張ってるんだから
まあそれで一人の子供で満足するしかないんですね
しかし 軽々と子育てできた人が
もう何のことない 子供はだいたい
どんな子供でも自分で成長するんだからね
まあただもう勝手に母親が私が育てたんだぞとかね
まあ人の特許をね 無許可で使用するだけなんですけど
あの 別に人間っていうのは誰でも自分一人で成長しますよ
それでまあ心配することなく
子供はまあすくすく成長していくならば
お母さんには余裕があるんですね
そうなってくると まあこんな可愛い子供だからね
もう一人いた方がいいな
もう一人いた方がいいなと
それで考えちゃうんですよ
やっぱりもう一人がよろしいと
欲しいとということは
今一人の子供で満足していないんですね
それで前に例に出すお母さんがもう一人の子供の面倒を見ることで
もうこりごり 精一杯 もうもう暇も余裕も何もない
その人はもう一人 二人目の子のことは期待しないんです
だからアンケート取ったら
私は一人の子で十分満足しているんだと
これ気楽に人に聞けば
もう一人欲しいんだけど
なかなか欲しいだけで授かるもんじゃないねとか言ったりする
それで満足の裏っていうのはわかると思いますよ
忙しいということなんですね
みんな日常の生き方で精一杯なので
社会は平和になっているんです
今説明したのはそういうところなんですね
政治家にしても 統治はとても楽なんです
世界で一番日本の政治家が幸せだと思います
やること何にもないんです
まあできればもう何か不正的で
なんかちょこっと金儲かるぐらいで
まあそれも下手くそですぐバレるし
で あと怠け者だから自分でそこはごまかしも自分でしないんです
秘書に任せるんですね
それでバレたりはするし
ただ 安全にして人を攻撃できれば
今の日銀の総裁みたいにね
日銀の総裁っていうのは
そう簡単に管理できる立場じゃないんだからね
まあすごい偉い仕事だから
国会にもそううかつに文句は言えない
今がチャンスと だから言いたい放題言ってやるぞとね
だから まあ日本の政治家って世界一幸せだと思いますよ
そういう時だけちょっとかっこつけるんですね
完璧に自分が安全ですから
では言ってやるぞと  それで社会が良くなるわけじゃないしね
命かけてやっているという何もかけてないしね
まあとにかく国が平和ということは誰でも楽なんですね
大体社会世間のことに瞬間的に興味を持つ場合以外
自分以外の以外 2つ入ってますね
自分以外のことに興味なく生きているんです
あの 私たちというかね
日本の社会ではもうあまり興味ない
他のことには まあ突然いきなりポーッとなんか興味が出ますけど
まあ大丈夫です  1 日で消えるんです
うん ものすごく大騒ぎしたり
キャーキャーって言うんですけど
もうこの国はどうなってるんで
何か出来事が起きるとどうなってるんでしょうかとかね
これではとんでもない
もう何とかしなくちゃ
急ぎ目を忘れているんです
そういうことだから あんまりまあ自分以外のことには興味ないということは
まあずっとある現象なんですね
そういうことで まとめて言いたいのは
もう日本の社会に聞けば満足しているということはよく言う
それを分析してみると
皆様方は余計なことを考える暇がなくて忙しいという結果なんです
ですから  満足しているというより満足していると言うしかないんです
なぜならば 不満になるような希望期待はもうないんです
希望期待あると不満になるんですよ
例えばサラリーマンで仕事をして
5  6年  7  8になってくると
もう自分はすごく忙しくて
朝から晩までもう能力ギリギリで
もう課長になる見込みなくなっちゃうんですね
課長に部長にとか もうとんでもない話だと
もうこれで十分だと 今から偉いんですよ
今ももう係長にもなれないぐらいで
今の仕事はもう精一杯
もうやりきれない状態であると
それで係長に まあもう流れでなっても悪くないんだけど
もうちょっとということで
課長部長なんかはもう話にならないという条件で来てるんですよ
だから満足しているんです
じゃあまあ今日は話できるだけ早く
不満になる前に早く終わりたいです
それで満足っていうのはそんなもんで
では不満ということは何でしょうかと
いろいろあります できるだけ今日の話は日本の社会に焦点当ててみたんです
なぜならば これは私に対する挑戦であって
何も満足を感じない 不満を感じない社会で不満について語るということはありえないんだから
標準的なレベルでまだ生きることはできない
生きることに標準レベルあるでしょうに
それにまだ達していない
その人はすごく不満になるんですよ
例えば大学を出ているのに
卒業してすぐ家に帰って
そのまま自分の部屋に座り込んでいる
お母さんがご飯作って部屋に運んであげなくちゃいけない
自分が食卓のダイニングとするところには降りてはこない
母親に文句を あんた何もやることないでしょうに
こちらに持ってきたらどうですかとかね
それでお母さんもはいはい
わかりましたと うちの子はすごく可愛い子で
まあまあ大学も出ていますよ
まあ家でいますけどと言って
もうこれは息子のご飯と言って部屋まで運んであげたりするんです
で まあお母さんにしてみれば世界一出来のいい息子かもしれませんだけど
社会から見ればまあ標準的な人間になってないんですね
だからその人はなんで家を出ないのかというと
家を出て店なんか飲み屋さんに行ったら社会に出会うんでしょ
それであんたもう仕事しないの？と聞くんですよ
何のこともなく まあもう学校終わったでしょ？とかね
お前今何やってるの？とか
それは聞きたくないんです
自分が世界一すごい偉いんだからね
だから家から出ません
家から出ちゃうと そのタイトルがもう外れるんですね
世界一という玄関から出ると
あるいはなんか抜けちゃう
あまりにもでっかすぎて
あるコマーシャルあるでしょ
なんかローンのコマーシャルが
なんかすっごい なんか一杯服を着て出ようと思ったら
全部もう取れしまったっていう
で まあそんな感じであまりにもでっかいタイトルを付けてますから
自分の家の玄関から出るとただの人間になっちゃうんですね
ですから この外は出ない
買い物にも行かない 家の中にいることになるんですね
そういう人々はちょこっと家を出たところで
むちゃくちゃ不安をというか
不満を感じる なぜ不満を感じるかというと
標準的なレベルに達していないんだからなんです
達してるんだったら もう仕事してますよとかね
もう会社に行ってますけどとか
でもあれ難しくてもう嫌とか何とか言って
もう対等に喋ることができます
そこでいくら仕事を失敗しました
ものすごく叱られた 怒鳴られたとかね
飲み屋さんで他のおじいさんとガチャガチャ文句言いながら言うこともできるできる人は一応満足しているんです
もう会社に入ったらバッカしだから
仕事は失敗ばっかりかもしれませんだけど
それで気分がよく頑張ってはいるんです
そういうわけで標準レベルに達していない
次のポイントは 欲が深い
希望 夢などはいっぱいある
自分の欲が深くて あるいはいろんな希望
夢がいっぱいあって こんなのがあったんだからって体は動かないでしょうに
我々は体と時間というこの 2つの制限あるでしょうに
何やってもその中で生きていなくちゃあかんでしょうに
しかし 夢っていうのは
希望っていうのは 欲っていうのは
肉体と時間を気にしないんですよ
だからものすごくあの観念的な妄想なんですね
だから欲が深いということはね
希望 夢などはいっぱいあるということは
まあ時空関係からずれているということで
話にならない だから不満にはなる
あるいは能力 才能がない場合はどうしますかね
社会はいろいろことを要求するんだけど
自分に能力 才能はない
まあ当然不満になるんですね
あの子供たちはよく不満でしょ
まあ親が好き勝手に妄想で観念で欲深くて
あれこれと子供に要求するんですね
あんた大きくなったらこうなりなさい
ああいう風になりなさい
医者になりなさいとかね
子供にはもう病院の床掃除ぐらいの能力しかないのに
お母さんがもう医者にしたいんですね
そうすると子供はすごく不満を感じるんだ
感じるんですよ 大体大人の子供は不満で子供
別に不満を感じなくてもいいでしょうに
不満感じるのは親の要求なんですね
そんなこと要求したっても
自分にそんな能力あるか
才能あるかもわからないし
おそらくないだろうと思ってるしね
これは大人でも同じことで
社会はいろんなことを要求する
しかし 自分には能力 才能がないという現象がある場合は
もう当然不安に不満になります
それから社会に言われることはまあ気になる
まあ社会とも自分以外のものは全部社会なんですよ
以外の世界は社会です
家族も それで社会っていうのは好き勝手に無責任で
何でもかんでも言っちゃうんですよ
人は聞いていようが聞いてなかろうが
それは社会はあまり気にしない
それで自分以外のいろんな社会と人々がいろんなことを言うと不満になりますよ
例えば もうあなたもう歌えないの？いきなり消えちゃうと
例えばどこかに行って
もう酒飲んで遊んでると
いきなりあんた歌えないの？これでいきなりショックでしょう
だから何聞くかわからないんですよ
そこは気になっちゃうとすごくもう苦しくて
もう不満になっちゃうんです
まあ例えば みんなでビール飲んでないのに
いきなりあんた焼酎飲めないの？とか言われた人とはいきなりショックになっちゃうんですよ
もし飲めない人だったらね
不満を感じない人はもう何？今はもうビールでしょうに
まあ関係ないものは聞くなよと言えますけど
普通は人間そんなこと言わないでしょうね
もし本人がビールは飲めるが焼酎は飲めない場合はいきなり不満感じるんです
だから社会に言われることを気になるとすごく不満を感じる
これ危ないんですよ この子供たちがすごく失敗するのは
親の言うことが気になるんだからなんです
まあ聞き流しちゃえばいいんですよ
で 聞き流すことができなくなっちゃう
できなくなると 子供はもうもう家族みんな殺す可能性もあります
だから気をつけた方がいいんですよ
日本ではそんなこと起きませんよと安心していても
やっぱり良くないと思いますよ
あまりにも例えばもう父親とか母親とかね
ガチャガチャ言うと 子供はこれすごい気になる性格だったら
だからまあ親は育てないという理屈なんですよ
子供は生まれつき何言われても気にしない性格だったら
もう親は懲らしませんよ
それで子供が大人になったら
私はこいつはしっかり育てましたと自慢する
とんでもない これあれ
もう何て言いますかね
快速ですね 自分の作品じゃないんですよね
それで子供はちょっとしたことを気になるような性格で生まれると
親は殺されて終わっちゃうんですね
キャーキャー言うと  その時は子供が悪いということにしちゃうんですね
だから子供が悪いか親が悪いかっていうことは成り立ちません
で ポイントは あなたが他人が言うことをものすごく気になる人かということなんです
余計に傷つく人でしょうかと
だからそこで まあもうもう社会でね
まあこれからもう親はこうやって子供を育てるべきだとかね
子供はこうなるべきだ
そんなこと言ってもそれは答えになりません
テレビでもね 世界一の一流のそういうカウンセラーとか専門家が来てテレビで喋ってるでしょうね
あれではもう一つの問題解決するっていうことはできません
そんな説法しても 問題は子供はどんな性格かっていうことは親はわからないしね
だから一人一人が自分が危険にならないようにと気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
その中で まあ他人言うことはあんまり気になる人はかなり不満で出てきて
不満がどんどんストレスになりましてね
我慢できなくなると ものすごく犯罪を起こしたり
いろんなことをやったりはする
だからで 気になる性格の人に物事を気にしないようにするぞということは大変な修行なんですよ
そう簡単ではないんです
私は今日からあまり人を言うことは気にしませんとかね
そんな簡単にできるならばね
ありがたいことで それはできませんね
だから結構気を付けて訓練しなくちゃいけない
自分自身でどうすれば良いのかわからない
それから次のポイントは
自分自身でどんな人間になればいいか
どうすればいいか どんな勉強をすればいいかとか
全然わからない それになってくるともう不満しかないんですよ
それって本当とんでもないことでね
もう小さいときから 自分が何するのかっていうことをはっきりしなくちゃいけないんです
だから自分でどうすればいいかわからない人々っていうのは
まあ一応小学校には行く
それからどうしても放り出しますから
中学校にも行く  友達も高校に行くんだから
親も高校のこと喋るんだから
まあなんとなく まあそこら辺どこかに高校に行っても大学にも行くかもしれません
でも自分ではもう ただまあどうしようもなく
しょうがなく進んだだけ
それが人間としては良くないんですよ
これやりたいというね
この学校に行きたいと
なければダメなんですよ
これ親反対来るかもしれませんだけど
なんであんな学校を選ぶのかとかね
それでも私があの学校に行きたいと決めた時点で
自分がなんとかしっかりしています
だから そのエネルギーはどこに変えてもいい方向へ変えます
だから この自分自身でどうすればいいかとわからなくても
甘えてもらって育てられちゃって
結局はもう次に何が残るかというと
ずっと不満なんですね
仕事をしなくちゃあかんだけど
ということになるんですね
仕事はやっぱりした方がいいんだけど
まああまりその仕事をする気になりませんとかね
仕事探しは本当に面倒くさいとかね
この間面接を受けたんですけど
厳しいことを言われたんだから
もう傷ついちゃったとか
なんとか言って 時々それも通じない場合は
なんか私に何か幽霊でも憑いてるんではないかという人もいるんですよ
なんか変な声聞こえますけどとかね
そうすると他の人々が
ああ さすがあなたね あれ
何て言いますか 霊感 霊感があってすごいいいですねと言ってくれればすごくありがたいんです
そうするとまた家に引っ込んで何もしないでいることができるんですね
霊能者だから まあ私は言うことは
まあ微妙にいろいろ嫌な経験があるんだから言ってるんです
このような人は不満で文句を言うんですね
こういう風なリストの人々は
それからもう満足ということを説明しました
不満ということは説明しました
じゃあそこで満足と不満のまあ合わせてみたら
不満組は大抵性格的に暗い
まあそれってのはわかりやすいんですね
不満組はもうどうしても暗い
道が外れると自己破産
またいつでももう直しておいたんですけど
このコンピューターは頭が良すぎて漢字は変えてくれるんです
道が外れると自己破壊か犯罪家になる恐れもあるんです
この不満組はちょこちょこっと行っちゃうと
もう何するかわからないんですね
すごく暗いんですよ これ
満足組はどうなるんでしょうかと
満足組の性格は明るく見えたり
傲慢に見えたりする すごい明るいなと言える場合もあるし
あんたちょっと 調子調子に乗るんじゃないないよと言う時もあります
あるいはちょっと乗りすぎじゃないのかとかね
まあまあ それに似ているもので
傲慢に見えたり あるいはすごく明るく見えたりはします
しかし 自分の決まっているパターンの生き方に以上変化が起きたら対応できない
途方に暮れることになる
暮れる あ 暮れる  それで満足組は一番明るくて
ちょっと調子に乗りすぎているんだけど
そのパターンがちょっとでも崩れちゃうと
もう大変です それは前に説明しました
なんで我々は満足かというと
あまりにも忙しいんだからなんです
決まってるパターンがあります
朝起きてからもう夜12時半 1時半までやることはもうびっしり決まってるんです
だからもうこんな考える暇がないんです
満足か不安かとかね もっと希望あるか
こんな希望を作る余裕がないんです
だから満足しているんです
しかし このパターンがちょっとでも変わると
もうどうすることもできなくなるんですよ
日本の社会でもあるでしょう
もう今まで本当にうまくいっていたのに
ちょっとしたことで全部崩れたっていう
ちょっとしたことで だから満足組のちょっと危ないところはそれ
だから まあこれとこれと結局はなんか似ているとこなんですよ
結局は不満組は明らかにもうわかって危ないんですよ
満足組はまあいつも人生流れるならばいいんだけど
ちょっと何か起きちゃうとどうするのかと
その瞬間に途方に暮れてしまっちゃうんです
ね まああまりもう具体的な例を言わなくてもわかると思いますね
で 満足組は世間の流れに身を任せているんです
これってすごい わかりやすいケースで
私たちはこのような流れも別に満足して楽しんでいるということは
世間に身を任せてますね
流れに わかりやすく言うと
みんなやっていることをやっていれば大丈夫だというね
世の中にまあ普通に言っていること
まあ普通に勉強して 普通に仕事をして
普通に結婚して まあ普通にもう流れに合わせていればそれで十分でしょうと
それで満足になるんです
だから満足組の特色は
世の中の流れに身をもう任せちゃって
そこで自己責任ちょこっと減るんですよ
不満組は世間の流れに適応できない
それで不満組っていうのは
世間の流れに適応できない
学校に行っても勉強できなくなる
もう友達と仲良くできないとかね
仲良くすることができないとか
もう先生はなんかちょっと態度でかいとか
なんとか言って もうもう生活できなくなっちゃうんですね
それは世間の流れに適応できないという
だから ダーウィンさんの法則によってね
もう大変なことになります
両方とも理性に基づいた生き方をしないんですね
だから世間に身を流す
世間の流れに身を任せていると言ったって
大して理性じゃないんですね
それが自分は無知な人は安全だけなんですね
そこで世間の流れに身を任すことできなくて
もう対立ばっかり喧嘩ばっかりしているという人も理性じゃないですよね
だからどちらでも理性じゃないんですね
両方とも感情に負ける
勝ち組も負け組も感情に簡単に負けています
問題が起きたら無知になるので解決できない
よく満足組のことを気をつけてください
皆様の中で別に不満組に入る人はいないと思いますから
あのまあ普通満足組の中でもそういうことはでき出ます
満足組はだいたい感情的です
だから感情が機能しちゃうと
もうまたシステムが壊れちゃう
自分の毎日のワンパターンが壊れる
それからこの毎日生きていくところで
何か新しい問題が起きちゃうと
どうしたらいいのかとわからなくなるんです
すごい簡単ですよ 普通
奥様たちもね 例えば毎日 3時半に買い物に買い物するそうで決まっている場合は
何かが起きて 3時半に買い物に行けなくなっちゃうんですね
これダメなんですよ それでどうしよう
どうしようと なんかもう北朝鮮から原発を送ったような感じで
もう大変なことになる
ちょっとしたことでも
だからまあそれをそれぐらいの精神で
人生ってのはいろいろ問題が起こるでしょ
突然 もう予測もしないものは対応できませんね
だから満足組っていうのはかなりもう大変ですよ
ちょっと満足は流れが良ければいいんですよ
だからこのあの この何年前からね
経済状況でちょこちょこと流れが良くなっちゃって
あのもう不動産を 土地を
もう買っては売る 買っては売るで
それで無茶儲かるんだぞとかね
それで銀行もお金出してくれるぞと
いきなりもうバブルになっちゃったんですね
バブルになったところで状況変わったでしょうね
半年でもう復活しなくちゃいかんのに
もう 6年  8年 経ってもできない
だからどんな穴でも放っておけば
どんどん埃 汚れ ホコリ溜まって穴が塞ぐでしょ
どこか穴掘ってみてください
１年ぐらいだってことも穴がないんですよ
ただ そんな感じで 今は日本はもうバブル状態から復活して
今経済成長の方向に行ってるんだぞとかね
発表ありますけどね すごくニコッと笑いながら言ってますけど
その時ネクタイもこうするんです
みんな 私は笑っちゃいますけどね
あのね 道路のそばに穴があってもね
半年ぐらいになると穴がないんだよと
だからこれぐらい待っていけば
どうせもうなんとかなりますよ
で それで私は言いたいのは
この価値組ではなくて
この満足組で生きている場合は流れに沿って生きていて
しかしちょこっと何か異常現象が起きちゃうと解決方法がないんでできないんで
ないではなくて だからこの電車とかね
大変危ないんです 全部マニュアルでないと
人が病気になったらどうしますか？ちゃんと本にないとどうなるかわかりませんよ
もう幸いに病気になったらこうします
人身事故を起こしたらこうしますという
まあ大体のことはもう一応推測できますから
まあマニュアル通りにはやってます
しかし そこにないものが起きたらどうしましょうかと
例えば電車に信号機人が待ってるでしょ
ホームに もうその瞬間に子供がおじいちゃん
おじいちゃんとね もう何かおもちゃを持つんですよ
面白いでしょうとか何とか言うと
じゃあこの人どうするのかと
私は試しにやってやりたいんですけど
残念ながらなかなか日本の子供はそういう自分でものを考えて行動しないんだから
どうにもない それは学校で教えてないんで
そういうことをするのはということになるんです
その時はまあそのホームに立っているおじいさんはどうするのかと
ちゃんと秒単位で計算して電車を信号出さなくちゃいけないしね
それで子供がなんか面白いことしたらちょっと
だから そういうこの決まってないものが起きちゃうところで
知恵ということなんですよ
その時解決できる人は失敗しないんですね
だから まあこの価値組ではなくて
価値組というのは日本の言葉で言うと
この満足組ですね 満足組の場合は一応解決できないということになるんです
両方もう必要な程度を超えて世間に依存している
満足組も不満組もあまりにも依存しています
世の中に 世の中の流れに身を任せているということは
世の中に依存していることでしょう
世の中の流れがちょこっと変わる
こちらも大パニック状態で失敗する
不満ぐいも同じこと 世の中はもう何でもできない
何でもできない 何でもできないと
世の中に対してもう攻撃するか
もうもう対立できない状態ですね
適応できない状態 勇 or 痴呆
どちらです